hi and welcome to my video series of
more bio concepts explained in three
minutes it's not a detailed explanation
but it has all the necessary information
to save your ass before the day of your
exam if you haven't yet subscribed to my
channel please subscribe now in this
installment we'll be talking about how
NIC translation works so NIC translation
is a technique which uses DNA polymerase
1 to level a specific sequence of the
DNA either fluorescently or
radioactively this technique which is
also known as head translation was
developed in 1977 by Rigby and Paul Berg
so Nick simply means giving a small cut
and translation means movement Sonique
translation means movement uppercut yes
you are right so the way Nick
translation works is you have a DNA of
interest where you put DNA polymerase
one which creates a cut now DNA
polymerase move from I prime to three
prime direction and as a result if you
give particular fluorescently level or
radioactively level nucleotide the
portion of that is going to be labeled
by the radioactive or fluorescently
label nucleotide so what you can see the
Nick that is produced has been
translated to a different region at the
same time a portion of the DNA is
labeled and that is how a radioactively
level could be generated generated by
the melting down the DNA partner or a
radioactively-labeled probe could be
generated which could be subsequently
used in fluorescence in situ
hybridization or in case of southern
hybridization or applications like that
I hope you enjoyed this video if you
liked this video give everybody comes a
poem for collections obscure thing